on peut être pré retraité est encore le
meilleur dans sa spécialité la preuve
alain prost vient d'être sacré champion
du monde de formule 1 pour la 4e fois
deux jours après avoir annoncé sa
retraite définitive de la compétition à
la fin de la saison
prost a terminé deuxième tout à l'heure
du grand prix du portugal derrière
l'armure schumacher après un grand prix
plein de suspense laurent frédéric
bollée 48 sur fil après avoir annoncé sa
future retraite
alain prost veut brandir fièrement le
drapeau français le voilà champion du
monde 93
il devait pour cela devancer son
coéquipier damon hill et avant même le
départ c'était chose faite
il calme et s'élance en dernière
position mais le héros du départ ce fut
bien jean alesi déchaîné d'avignonet qui
se permet de griller sur sa ferrari
sénat hakkinen et prost parti prudemment
pour ce dernier tout se poursuit
d'ailleurs pour le mieux puisque senna
abandonne peu après à ruth alors les
changements de pneus allez-y et actimel
les jeunes nous se frottent l'un à
l'autre mais rétrograde ou profiter
williams et de prost
roth qui se retrouve deuxième derrière
michael schumacher l'allemand le
quittera plus cette position
un grand prix du portugal marquée par
deux accidents spectaculaires
mika hakkinen le finlandais remplaçant
d'andretti s'envole et s'en va taper
fort le rail
et puis surtout gerard bergen qui
s'introduit là où ne l'attend pas
incroyable à la sortie des stands
l'autrichien a dérapé
un miracle finalement qu'il ne soit pas
venu s'encastrer dans une ou deux autres
voitures
mais depuis le grand prix en tout cas
les accidents graves se succèdent
entraide prost est revenu sur schumacher
mais ne ne doublera pas le jeune
allemand remporte donc le deuxième grand
prix de sa carrière il est bien un
prodige
ross en poche ou quatrième titre il est
bien prodigieux victoire donc de
schumacher 85 86